ya lo decíamos justo vamos a directo a y
hoy nos desplazamos hasta Buenos Aires
porque el 6 de diciembre se prevé que se
conozca El veredicto en el juicio por
presunta corrupción contra la
vicepresidenta Cristina Fernández de
kirchner Quien salió ilesa de un
atentado en septiembre y días antes la
fiscalía había pedido 12 años de prisión
y su inhabilitación de por vida para
cargos públicos conectamos con Natalia
corresponsal de France 24 en Buenos
Aires natalio que dijo la ex mandataria
en su comparecencia de hoy
Esta es la tercera vez que habla y la
última en el marco de este juicio dijo
este tribunal es un pelotón de
fusilamiento dice puede ser Si se quiere
el título más claro en el que ella Busca
señalar que se trata de una suerte de
persecución política organizada en torno
a la causa es algo que viene señalando
de ella y su defensa desde el inicio de
esta causa también trazó paralelismos
con la causa que Investiga el intento de
asesinato en su contra cuando señaló que
aquella causa parece no avanzar como
ella considera que debe avanzar mientras
esta avanza como ella considera que no
debe avanzar de hecho más tarde publicó
en su sitio web una lista de las que
llaman las 20 mentiras de la causa de la
causa vialidad en la que con argumentos
que ya presentó su defensa Busca
desarmar Si se quiere los argumentos de
la acusación sabremos recién a quién le
da más peso el tribunal cuando llegue la
lectura de esta sentencia como bien
decía es el día 6 de diciembre bueno es
factible que el Jurado imponga la pena
que está pidiendo la fiscalía
bueno Cristina Fernández dice
prácticamente desde el inicio que ella
considera que ya está escrita esta
sentencia de antemano esta sentencia en
su contra Más allá de si efectivamente
el tribunal va a dictar en una sentencia
en su contra de 12 años o va a
determinar que sea otra la pena de
cárcel o la inhabilitación o no la
realidad es que no está del todo Claro
que vaya a ocurrir hay que esperar a ver
qué anuncia el tribunal el día 6 y hay
que recordar que a partir de ese momento
a instancias de apelación que pueden
llegar hasta la Corte Suprema de
Justicia y además la vicepresidenta
cuenta con fueros que la protegen y le
dan inmunidad contra penas de cárcel Y a
partir de los 70 años además que está
por cumplir también quedaría exenta de
cumplir una pena de cárcel en prisión
sino que sería en prisión domiciliaria
pero recordemos que estos son pasos que
todavía están por llegar Porque primero
viene la lectura de la sentencia y luego
las potenciales apelaciones